since we're doing a whirlwind
introduction to all of economics
uh i've been talking to a few
objectivists recently
and just you know ayn rand comes up as a
as a person as a philosopher throughout
many conversations a lot of people
really despise her
a lot of people really love her it's
always weird to me
when uh somebody arouses a philosophy or
a human being arouses that much emotion
in either direction
does she make do you understand first of
all that level of emotion
and what are your thoughts about ayn
rand and her philosophy objectivism
is it useful at all to think about this
kind of formulation of
rational self interest if i could put in
those words
or i guess more negatively
the the the selfishness or she would put
i guess the virtue of selfishness
ein rand was a big influence on me
growing up the book that really mattered
for me was capitalism the unknown ideal
the notion that wealth creates
opportunity and good lives
and wealth is something we ought to
valorize and give very high status
it's one of our key ideas i think it's
completely correct
i think she has the most profound and
articulate statement of that idea
that said as a philosopher i disagree
with her on most things
and i did even like as a boy when i was
reading her i read plato before in rand
and in a socratic dialogue there's all
these different points of view being
thrown around
yeah and who whomever it is you agree
with you understand the wisdom is in
the coming together at the different
points of view yeah and she doesn't have
that so
altruism can be wonderful in my view
humans are not actually that rational
self-interest is often poorly defined to
pound the table and say existence exists
i wouldn't say i disagree but i'm not
sure that it's a very meaningful
statement
i think the secret to iran is that she
was russian i'd love to have her on my
podcast if she was still alive
i'd only ask her about russia which she
mostly
never talked about after writing we the
living and she
is much more russian than she seems at
first even like purging people
from the objectivist circles it's like
how russians especially
female russians so often purge their
friends it's weird
all the parallels so you're saying so
yes
so i um assuming she's still not around
uh but if she is and she comes into your
podcast see
can you dig into that a little bit do
you mean like the pers her personal
uh demons around the
social and economic uh russia of the
time
when she escaped the promise she
suffered there yeah what she really
likes in the music and literature and
why she
can literature and getting deeply into
that her view of relations between the
sexes and russia
how it differs from america why she
still
carries through the old russian vision
in her fiction this extreme
sexual dimorphism but with also very
strong women
and he is a uniquely at least eastern
european
uh vision mostly russian i would say
and that's in her that's her actual real
philosophy not this
table bounding existence exists and
that's not talked about enough
he's a russian philosopher yeah like
she's or soviet whatever you want to
call it
and if she wasn't so certain she could
have been
a dostoevsky where it's not that that
certainty is almost the thing that uh
brings of the adoration of uh millions
but also the hatred of millions
he became a cult figure in a somewhat
russian-like manner
yeah yeah it is it is what it is uh but
i love the idea that
i again you're just dropping bombs that
are poetic
that the wisdom is in the coming
together of ideas
it's kind of interesting to think that
no one human
possesses wisdom no one idea
is the wisdom that the coming together
is the wisdom
like in my view boswell's life of
johnson 18th century british biography
it's in essence a co-authored work
boswell and johnson it's one of the
greatest philosophy books ever
though it is commonly regarded as a
biography john stuart mill
who in a sense was co-authoring with
harriet taylor
a better philosopher than his realized
though he's rated very very highly
plato socrates a lot of the greatest
works
are in a kind of dialogue form curtis
faust
would be another example it's very much
a dialogue
and yes it's drama but it's also
philosophy shakespeare
maybe the wisest thinker of them all
you